Село Гребінки Київської області.
Поки новенька швидка від початку місяця стоїть зі зламаною ходовою,
на виклики виїжджає ось цей ретро-автомобіль.
Двері тут не зачиняються, тож усе необхідне обладнання
фельдшер Людмила Курнієнко зберігає на підстанції
й щоразу перед виїздом комплектує автомобіль.
Та це не найбільша проблема.
В салоні автомобіля російського Ульянівського заводу
2007 року випуску не розвернутись, не піднятись,
тож надати належну допомогу хворим  неможливо.  Крім того,
не розрахована така швидка і на кисневий балон, який так потрібен
при перевезенні хворих на СOVID-19.
Хворі дратуються, сердяться.
Вони і так погано почуваються, все це додає їм ще нервового стресу,
і стан їхній погіршується. А машина не приспособлена до хворих.
Немає кисню, вікна не відкриваються.
Транспортування довге.
Людмила працює фельдшером вже майже 30 років.
Такого навантаження на швидку та кількості важкохворих не пригадує.
Це вперше така епідемія. Вони тяжчі, вони задихаються,
не можуть ні сидіти, ні говорити.
Коли ми їх госпіталізуємо, вони в тяжких станах.
Задихаються,
синюшність,
постійно кашляє, може бути сухий кашель...
Перший виклик сьогодні - не через COVID.
Швидка мчить із максимальними для неї 70 кілометрами на годину
до сусіднього Василькова. Відстань не близька -  30 кілометрів.
За нормальних умов цей дзвінок мала б прийняти
місцева підстанція швидкої, та дві їхні бригади вже на викликах.
Зокрема, в сусідній Боярці вже понад годину не можуть
здати в лікарню пацієнтку з підозрою на коронавірус.
Чекали ми десь добру годину,
може, навіть півтори.
Не хотіли приймати. Ось так домовились дві лікарні:
Васильків і ця. І проводили всі обслідування в машині,
не те щоб у відділі.
Від 7 до 15 викликів за день.
З машини не вилазимо.
Тут і обідаємо. У нас район здоровий,
і ми можемо і в другий район поїхати, якщо немає машин.
Кілометраж бував 600 із лишнім км за сутки. Це немало.
Нині в нон-стоп умовах працюють усі швидкі Київщини.
Медзаклади, відкриті для хворих на COVID-19, переповнені,
тож бригадам разом із хворими доводиться годинами чекати,
поки диспетчерська знайде та домовиться з лікарнями
про вільне місце. Між відстанню, станом пацієнта і наявністю ліжок
в лікарні вирішальним є останнє.
Пацієнтів ми навіть в Переяслав-Хмельницький - це дуже далеко -
і в Макарів, це 120 км в одну сторону.
Ми возимо туди, де є місця.  Для нас пріоритет - де є місця,
а де ближче - це не є пріоритетністю.
З весни в Київській області хворих на Covid розміщували
в семи лікарнях, тепер  таких  удвічі більше - п'ятнадцять.
Втім, і зараз ліжок не вистачає. У Василькові, який віднедавна
входить у червону зону епіднебезпеки,  в лікарні об'єднали
дитяче і доросле інфекційні відділення.
Офіційно тут 55 ліжок, та прийняти таку кількість хворих не можуть.
Їх немає, цих ліжок. Це дитячі ліжка.
Я ж не покладу на мале ліжко людину зі 100 кг.
І немає можливості технічно покласти.
Немає кисневого забезпечення, кисневої магістралі…
Відсутність кисню - ще одна проблема, через яку пацієнтам
дедалі частіше відмовляють у госпіталізації.
Ми були в Глевасі, жінка потребувала госпіталізації.
Ми пропонували в лікарню, в яку вже нам дадуть "добро",
але без кисню. Сказали, що кисню нема.
І хвора, її родичі відмовились.
І ми важку залишили вдома.
Осад залишається.
Ми не можемо допомогти і в лікарнях немає кисню...
Всі медичні служби області вже давно працюють
понад свої можливості. Диспетчерська щодня приймає
до чотирьох тисяч дзвінків замість колись максимальних двох тисяч.
Що буде, якщо коронавірус пробереться в ці стіни,
тут бояться уявляти.
Схожий страх є й серед медиків швидкої. Навіть якщо наразі
вони забезпечені системами захисту: мають як одноразові,
так і багаторазові костюми.
Тим часом швидка фельдшера Людмили мчить уже
на новий виклик.  Цього разу понад 40 кілометрів долають за 40 хвилин.
Після огляду пацієнта - 70-річного дідуся -
ухвалюють рішення його не госпіталізувати.
Не забираємо, немає потреби, сатурація нормальна,
температура хороша. Хрипів немає в легенях,
результату ПЛР немає, просто всі члени сім'ї перехворіли.
До того ж, транспортування на таких автомобілях хворим,
особливо похилого віку, дається непросто. А скільки ще часу
стоятиме без ремонту нова, але зламана швидка, - невідомо.
Для екстреної допомоги це не поодинокий випадок
простою автомобіля.  Ще дві швидкі Васильківської підстанції
чекають на ремонт.
Коли начальству говориш, що треба зробити те і те, то начальство:
що грошей немає, потерпіть і покатайтесь. От ми і докатались...
на цій машині. Я не знаю, що і на який час…
Лопнула пружина  і два тижні стояла.
Казали, що чекайте місяць, поки на майстерні звільниться місце.
А там роботи на дві години.
У Києві пояснюють, що питання навіть не в грошах.
Наразі ремонт спецтехніки здійснює після тендерних процедур
обмежена кількість підрядників. Аби перейти на прямі договори,
треба змінити низку документів. Мовляв, нині над цим працюють.
Тим часом фельдшерка Людмила на ретро-швидкій  поспішає
на черговий виклик рятувати життя.
Звільнитис? Ні. Професію свою люблю. Працюю за бажанням. Це моє.